Tổng thống Mỹ đô nên trăm cho biết, ông sẽ đẩn đơn kiện từ Nguyễn Joc Times tại
thoại trò án li bang fory đã yêu cầu buổi thường mới lắm tỷ đủ là Mỹ theo tổng thủ Trump,
tổ bóng này đến nhiều lần suyên ta, buôi nhỏ và buồn khóng cả như nông, gia đình xe nghiệp,
cũng như các phòng trào chính trị giống phát động.
Trên mạng giói chút số số ông cá buồn Nguyễu Times theo đổi một mua hình làm dụng lâu sài,
có thể lành vị bất thật pháp và không thể chức nhật.
Tổ bóng này đưa ra chỉ ít hành sau khi tổn Nguyễu Times đang lập bài liên qua đêm một quan hệ giữa tổng thống Trump,
và tổ phố ông Zem Jepery Epstein, bốn gây nhiều trình cải trong dụng lượng Mỹ,
hiện tại Nguyễu Times chưa đưa ra bị lộn chính thức.
Bộ kẻ nếu sinh ra sẽ phía tục làm ra thăng thăng thẳng thẳng giữa tổng thống Trump,
và chuyên thông sống chính, đồng thời đàn xanh như trình lộn về sang dời giữa tụng xong báo chiế,
và quyền bảo vệ sinh dựa khán nhân trong chính trường Mỹ.